oh man did you see that
sorry about that folks I tried to keep
it non offensive oh don't look at that
oh how do you respond it out I know boom
Oh picked up on that who picked up on
that ah I don't even have to say it if
you are familiar with some basic
openings in chess you will know what I
just did uh okay let's go I'm getting on
this diagonal before my opponent the
bird is the word if you didn't know
actually I did it say after all didn't I
f4 okay let's go [ __ ] up you know you
want to play and so does this [ __ ] up
III Bishop b5 kill the night I don't
have to worry about this guy okay III um
let's pin a knight
what else is my light-square bishop
gonna do right here a six chop chop get
in a d3 c4 structure this has happened
before if you've been tuned into the
stream you'll know a formation that you
could be running with if you shatter the
queenside structure here I don't know if
shatters may be a bit much but if you
damage the the structure in some form
having doubled see pawns and work
against this Bishop trying to arrest
this Bishop in some way restrict it
could be a good plan to run with now is
my opponent concerned about having
potential doubled C pawns
we're gonna see now what mmm
to that my opponent says I do not want a
deal
let's not castle I do not want to deal
with CC pawns and okay now I'm going to
take I was hesitant to play d3 you'll
note because of a queen a5 move I'm not
losing stuff but I'm close to losing
stuff I don't really want to play Knight
c3 I do want to play this still after
maybe the possibility to damage the
structure to damage the structure only
in chess will you hear that Queen c7
chop now actually Queen here I'm not
chopping anything my knight wants to
play one day and I think having a pond
on d3 is a good idea so I could pivot
and then he could follow in this
knight's footsteps d3 92 Knight f3 Queen
e1 Queen coming out over here probably
good idea let's go up on this night
isn't being challenged let's go night I
maintain control over this square now
there is an opportunity to make sure I
get this Bishop back and maybe I should
maybe what's the plan here if I don't
take the bishop can back up and then an
eventual d4 move this could be a an
annoying square let's let's do this
actually
let's go Knight where do you want to go
this is your home get to your home right
now e5 maybe Queen f3 there's gonna be
maybe this move I have to be concerned
about the C file could be ripped open
real soon
tempo gainer what's the clock situation
the Queen's gonna calmly come back this
is the most natural square keeping
pressure on the night staying out of
tricky
knife forks is something like this crazy
probably let's not do it I want to get
in Queen g3 and woo I don't know
actually that's not working how about
Knight takes Knight and then pawn push
and go for that let's go with this f5 is
the break because guess what these rooks
want to play and for as long as I just F
pawn is around for as long as I don't
engage with my opponents pawns they're
not gonna play this is something that
has to be dealt with this possibility
for f6 a shattered King side structure
is possible this drops a pun for a
moment I actually thought it was
available and what else
tick-tick-tick less than two minutes Oh
shutting off the connection with my
bishop hmm so much for this move the
bishop dish just takes now if I take
like this I have to worry about my C
pawn I don't want to worry about my C
pawn my pawns are well placed it's
coordinated well let's go Bishop do
something over here okay here's the plan
the plan is deal with the C file opening
up and in the meantime go after my
opponent oh okay well let me stop this
first what's my opponent ready to do
they're ready to trade off dark strip
bishops so no don't you dare I don't
want you to play to g5 and I'm on the
pun also Bishop h6 is a threat maybe
actually it is Oh actually f6 Bishop h6
is met with that
three pawn I'm going to take the free
pawns
I think it's a freebie checking once
checking twice it's a free pawn that was
missed and now there's serious trouble
because guess what my epon is gonna have
something to say about the position he's
gonna get to e5 and the pond is gonna
get to f6 the rook is gonna eventually
get here that's okay
he 5 f6 and the bishop is actually
trapped
if this pawn is pushed I think I just
let it sit let's go pon do something and
I'm a little scared Queen here
threatening Bishop h6 and try that this
is a threat Bishop h6 rook f7 is met
with the pawn push which is lethal
Bishop can't move there's probably pawn
takes needed or a king here pon tanks
are king there this isn't good now more
material uh-oh the bird bird versus bird
it's a video game isn't it something
like that anyhow rook f7 e 6 what's the
best continuation might it be a whole
rook my opponent goes down pawn push I
chop this is a little thing to deal with
maybe this should have come sooner less
than 20 okay II 6 for the win chop with
the check and then kill the king
rook for a Pawnee and then just retreat
the bishop actually I don't have to
retreat the bishop because my pawn is
guarding g8 and that would be me support
point just in time and the Queen is
actually a freebie actually this is a
cool mate the bishops pinned I almost
missed that I was gonna take the Queen
taking the king is better though that is
me okay good game let's back up here and
see how either one of us could have
improved okay
my first improvement is to actually
change that picture my first suggestion
now it's okay I guess okay yeah I don't
like showing those pictures on the
stream you just threw the bird it like
over 700 people and they did nothing to
you anyhow birds opening
I'm on this diagonal I don't know about
the pawn move get this Bishop out right
maybe get him out here or here and then
play this maybe like h6 you could tuck
them back or something but I wasn't I
wasn't too worried about things I'm too
worried about things as soon as I saw
that Bishop was disconnected from my
side of the board I guess that's one way
to kind of phrase it so you throw a
question to it that's true that's a main
suggestion cuz I'm feeling pretty
comfortable maybe another one is to
challenge this night maybe Bishop d6
although okay maybe this was a maybe I
there was some concern my opponent had
here about double deaf pawns because
guess what if you play Bishop d6 Knight
takes Bishop Queen takes Knight I could
be playing Bishop takes Knight but I
don't know if that's really a good idea
because dealt with that double deaf pawn
the one on f6 is controlling e5 which is
what you try to do in the white
I'm though on the white side here you're
trying to pivot about on this e5 square
and if you're controlling that that's
certainly going to be a very difficult
thing for me to you know what would I do
if you take away that one square I was
trying to devise a plan around so
nothing other words maybe Bishop d6 is
actually a decent idea and another thing
is that I mean you're not even Castle
kingside right if we if we could still
run with this some visual calculation
here Bishop d6 let's just say I run with
it immediately and I takes Bishop Queen
takes Knight Bishop takes Knight pawn
takes you could Castle queenside throw a
rook on the G file and maybe already be
pointing at g2 you're clean would at
that point be on c6 there's maybe
something going on there and I think
this is a pretty decent home for your
king right okay your books rolling on
the G
okay so that's the other suggestion I'm
feeling pretty good here I think White
House stands better because this is a
very annoying pond I wonder if the best
resistance is to actually take and we
get the Queen's off the board and you
have to deal with a rook having pressure
but I think you just defend rook d8 and
maybe f6 and get your king over to this
East six square you follow that takes
takes takes takes my rook is on this
pawn rook d8 and as follow-up moves can
be playing f6 to release any pressure on
f7 but more so to allow for King f7 to
e6 because if there is a pawn you're
going to if you if you need to have one
of your Center pawns watched over by a
piece the piece that's going to be most
comfortable with that is your King
because guess what that's where he wants
to be anyway it's convenient in the
endgame the king wants to be in the
center and he could be in the center and
watch over upon at the same time okay